the White House confirmed reports that
President Trump and Russian President
Vladimir Putin spoke twice during the
recent g20 summit only the first meeting
was known about at the time the second
discussion was not revealed until this
weekend for a fact at first broke on
Charlie Rose's show on PBS the White
House says the president spoke to Putin
informally at the end of a dinner
President Trump had an angry response to
the news tweeting even a dinner arranged
for the top 20 leaders in Germany is
made to look sinister major Garrett is
at the White House following this
unfolding story major good morning good
morning everything about this meeting is
different and in some startling ways no
White House aide or national security
adviser was present translation
typically the work of both countries was
provided solely by the Russians it
appears there's no recording or no notes
were taken of this conversation and
quite obviously the White House felt no
need to disclose it to traveling White
House reporters with the president at
the g20 a highly anticipated meeting
between President Trump and Russian
President Vladimir Putin earlier this
month wasn't the only FaceTime between
the two world leaders it turns out there
was another conversation hours later at
a dinner attended by the g20 leaders
video shows mr. Trump taking his seat
across the table from mr. Putin and
First Lady Melania Trump later on mr.
Trump reportedly left his seat to go to
speak with mr. Putin for nearly an hour
using mr. Putin's translator the White
House yesterday was forced to
acknowledge the previously undisclosed
conversation calling it brief and
informal describing claims it was trying
to hide the meeting as false malicious
and absurd late last night the president
took to Twitter to defend himself saying
fake news story of secret dinner with
Putin is sick all g20 leaders and
spouses were invited by the Chancellor
of Germany press knew in retrospect I
probably would have done things a little
differently the revelation comes as the
list of attendees at Donald Trump
Junior's 2016 meeting with the Russian
lawyer continues to grow CBS News has
confirmed I
alizée a soviet born businessman who
came to the u.s. in 1991 was also in
attendance along with son-in-law Jared
Kushner campaign chairman Paul Manafort
the Russian lawyer and a Russian
American lobbyist
Koval a disease lawyer claims his client
thought he was there to serve as an
interpreter but wasn't needed he did not
say a single word at the meeting and
left scratching his head wondering why
am I here
the meeting took place at the request of
Russian oligarch Aris aguillera who has
close ties to Vladimir Putin Cavallo Z
works for a company owned by a gala Rob
Cavallo days names surfaced in 2000 some
financially curious ways a US government
report identified him as someone who had
set up on behalf of Russian brokers
hundreds of bank accounts in two US
banks the report said there was evidence
this was part of a money laundering
operation for Russian and Eastern
European companies and that the amount
involved exceeded 1 billion dollars
Charlie thanks major